Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Sag mal, wann war jetzt eigentlich nochmal unsere Veranstaltung?
Remember, remember the 5th of November.
Jawoll! Keine neue Ausgabe von Logbuch Netzpolitik. Stattdessen wollen wir euch jetzt endlich mal erzählen, wann es denn jetzt mal losgeht. Denn, wie ihr euch schon gedacht habt, das Ganze findet jetzt statt am 5. November 2016. Und zwar so gegen 18 Uhr. Spätestens dann müsstet ihr euch also eingefunden haben. Um 19 Uhr gibt es dann unsere tolle Vorband. Und ja, irgendwie endet das Ganze so gegen Mitternacht.
Also genau zur richtigen Zeit, um danach noch ins Berghain zu gehen. Denn das Ganze findet statt in Berlin, im ehemaligen Stummfilmkino Delphi in Berlin-Weißensee, in der Gustav-Adolf-Straße 2. Wir haben da wirklich eine ganz besondere Location aufgetan. Da gibt es eine schöne Bar, da gibt es eine schöne Bühne, da gibt es eine schöne Wand, mehrere sogar. Es ist wirklich ein traumhafter Location. Wir sind unglaublich glücklich, dass wir sie haben. Und deswegen veranstalten wir dort die 200. Sendung. Das hast du nämlich noch gar nicht gesagt.
Nein, das habe ich nicht erzählt, weil das wollte ich jetzt erzählen. Logbuch Netzpolitik 200. Es wird auch wirklich die 200. sein. Onstage mit interessanten Gästen, mit viel Spaß am Gerät. Und, ja, wer ist die Vorband? Eine kleine Überraschung. Niemand Geringeres als das Team von Methodisch inkorrekt wird uns erläutern, wie das mit der Politik eigentlich wirklich funktioniert.
Da stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wenn ihr ein solches Paket in einer wunderbaren Location mit wunderbarer Vorband, mit wunderbaren Logbuch Netzpolitik bekommt. Was kostet der ganze Spaß? Und es ist unglaublich, Tim. Kostendeckung erreichen wir bei nur 23 Euro pro Person.
Nein.
Wahnsinn. Es ist unglaublich.
Das ist ja Ausverkauf.
Damit wir da auch noch was von haben, könnt ihr aber auch ein Unterstützer-Ticket kaufen. Da könnt ihr den Preis frei wählen und in ein Feld eintragen. Und das ist eigentlich auch ganz einfach. Denke an eine hohe Zahl und nehme sie mal zwei. Und schon bist du supporter. Und wenn du richtig abgehen willst, dann holst du dir einen geilen Logenplatz für einen noch geileren Preis. Denn von den Logenplätzen gibt es eine unglaublich beschränkte Anzahl. Dafür aber eine einmalige Sicht über die gesamte Veranstaltung und den Veranstaltungsort. Klickt schnell, weil solange der Vorrat reicht, reicht er. Und das ist bestimmt nicht lang. Ihr könnt sofort bezahlen mit den Datenschutz-suboptimalen PayPal. Dafür zahlt ihr einen Aufpreis oder kostengünstiger, aber langsamer mit Good Old Sepa. Das heißt, da müsst ihr euch noch mehr beeilen. Kauft, kauft, kauft.
Und zwar unter logbuchnetzpolitik.de/200abdonnerstag, dem 20. Oktober. Und das ist eigentlich schon alles, was ihr wissen müsst über diese tolle Veranstaltung, die demnächst über euch hereinbricht. Eine Sendung gibt es vorher noch mal auf diesem Kanal. Und ansonsten sehen wir uns am 5. November. Remember, remember. Remember.